thank you
[Music]
did you guys know that every person in
South Korea
suddenly becomes at least a year younger
after they just changed a very simple
law
oh they're counting the they're not
counting the zero anymore or they're oh
okay that's what it is they're taking
into account time spent in the womb
a lot a lot of Asian cultures do that
like some Chinese people will do that
too where it's like when you're born
you're technically one
really but then I thought because they
didn't have the number zero
maybe I don't know they don't no because
no I don't think so I thought that's how
they did it how do they explain how many
zeros they don't have
we go we have zero zeros
for five or six Chinese people talk to
your six but in America you're five yeah
and then so I think it's it's like a
pretty common Asian thing I feel like
because I know Koreans do it too do you
guys do that [__] I've always thought
about this because I'm like aren't I
nine months older than I than I am did
they count I think they count like the
day you're born as the first year isn't
it in America until you're actually born
you're not even a human yeah yeah so
when you're born it's a zero and then
your first month out of the womb you're
one month yeah inside the skin yeah
you're not non-personal and you can't no
you can't uh be murdered nope nope you
can't vote either even at the last
moment when you're going through labor
unless the baby's out but then if the
baby goes back in then you gotta start
all over that's a whole [__] thing
it's [__] wild dude what the [__] is
happening so yeah South Koreans they
just changed this law so now like it
takes effect a lot I guess last
Wednesday
so now people are like oh I guess I'm a
different age now they're younger I
think everyone's younger by one I mean I
guess No One's Gonna complain about that
right that is pretty crazy because it's
such a like a deep-rooted cultural thing
so now it's like a big shift in culture
like oh we're not going to recognize
that tradition that we used to do I
think there's a lot of things like that
because
um like child mortality back in the day
was common so like you know how Koreans
do the hundred day yeah oh yeah because
it's like most if they were gonna
survive the chances are more likely
after their hundred day so then they
don't really celebrate so with on the
hundredth day they kind of have like a
birthday party celebration for the baby
like for the baby big one yeah but I
think before that they don't really like
get too excited and it's and it's rooted
in like child mortality they don't even
make eye contact with them but that's
the 100 days almost like a bigger event
than their first year birthday it's
almost like they made it to 100 and then
they like have all the like gifts and
stuff and they dress the kid up and I
was like fancy like close that's cute
it's it's it was longer for
um Japanese it was like I want to say
like eight or ten that's you know that
movie uh eight years old yeah because
you know you know um Spirited Away and
things like that oh yeah
so the the thought behind it is well
because kids would die back then like my
all was like yeah the reason why we had
so many siblings is because like kids
die now Joe
a lot of us wouldn't survive
so they didn't want to get their hopes
up until they're like pretty sturdy yeah
and then like they believe that kids are
connected to the spirit world so then so
that yeah that movie Spirit Away the
concept is also like
that kid could see all the ghosts and
[__] and the parents can't because
they're connected to the spirit world
until they're a certain age so they're
like halfway in that world halfway in
our world and then so once they shed
that and then they get past a certain
age they're like oh now you're a human
dude I need to watch that movie do you
think like in Asia are they kind of
upset that like a traditional thing is
being changed I don't know I don't know
how they would feel about because I also
feel like Koreans are pretty like
receptive of like Western culture
they're probably doing it because it's
like this globalization that we have
yeah let's just all kind of speak on the
same terms because it's easier yeah it
seems like they're pretty like they
receive stuff well you know like they
just westernize really well so I don't
know yeah because it's like no one's
using the lunar calendar for their
official birthday anymore everyone's on
a Gregorian like the Western calendar my
mom's [__] tripping all the time yeah
she gets the dates wrong well she keeps
celebrating the [__] birthday that's
not on a license i'm like [__] that's
not even the one on the license yeah
you're gonna [__] like you feel like
BJ's trying to get a free Pazuki and you
show them their license what the [__]
[__] [__] tripping yeah celebrating
like two months early unless she's at
BJ's Arcadia so it's that far off
it could be like anywhere from like 30
days to like 60 days off depending
really yeah I am they're just but you're
never gonna change old people old people
are just gonna do whatever they're gonna
do your mom's committed bro she's
committed to the game a little bit
Superman maybe yeah
how come you don't [__] celebrate
birthday a couple months out of there
it's weird yeah dude I got a buddy who
um so he had a miss him and his wife had
a miscarriage two I think two was like
twins right and then they were basically
uh like when we when we knew they were
gonna have a kid and it was like things
were going good we were gonna throw him
a shower like to surprise them but then
like they kind of caught wind a little
bit and they're like hey like don't
throw a shark
oh [__] that must be tough oh no
this is where like a rule of thumb where
you wait a couple months until you
announce stuff yeah I think like three
months three months right even inside
anything's gonna happen yeah yeah so
scared well yeah why I mean he's he's
very like um
it's weird too because like the
miscarriage that they had it was like a
five month old pregnancy and so like man
yeah and so one time I was like busting
his balls I was like dude let's do your
[__] dad while I got everything in
your goddamn wallet and he's like those
are the medical bracelets from my kids
that I was like oh Jesus [__] Christ
is he a funny guy yeah yeah you [__]
with me for sure oh yeah you were just
like oh God damn
don't you love being that guy oh dude
and he had that rye grin on his face too
he's like I know I got this son of a
[__]
yeah
yeah you just don't think about [__]
like that no yeah
I feel like we're a part of this
generation that don't really see death
every day like it's not that common
because like when I spoke to like my
grandma when she was alive like the way
she talked about it it just seemed like
what people just died you know like all
the time like kids everybody all the
time and then she worked at a hospital
as an administrator so it was just like
super normal you know yeah and I'm like
man the it's actually more common for
you know it to be difficult during you
know pregnancy and then the kid even
like
gets uh birth after birth like surviving
through childhood was difficult and then
beyond that right but then now it's like
it's rare or like you just don't hear
about it or like it's kind of it's kind
of goes away quick because we don't want
to talk about it really that's that's
what it is what it is yeah and life
expectancy is up but also the back in
the day like I remember my mom saying
just a lot of things were just
shruggable like oh you have this illness
that's it I mean there's no treatment
not in this island you know what I mean
like depending on where you are yeah
back in the day you catch a cold you die
and I've got antibiotics and [__] no
yeah dude two months ago so I lost my
grandma right two months ago and then
the Hughes give me so much [__] that day
she was like how many grandmas you got
and I was like uh she's like I have one
and she's like you know totally give me
[__] and stuff but then
Grandma's you got yeah the shoes give me
[__] all day she's right with the tally
that's a counter yeah Stevers Nikki
grandmas then she talked a little too
much [__] I think because her Grandma's
about to die like any minute right now
oh Karma
what's your angle that you're playing
then oh I'm gonna be like hey Nikki how
many grandmas you got today
honestly don't be a [__]
that response always grants a [__] yeah
yeah yeah that's a fun game to play it's
pretty fun answer now that's how we deal
with anything is through humor yeah I
love doing that [__] it's the best
because what else are you gonna do what
else are you gonna do it's gonna be sad
about it all the time yeah she's like
how many grandmas do you think you have
out of ten I'm like zero
that's that's one of my one of my best
friends one of my best friends since
like I was five his his dad died
recently and then I was like well at
least you're you know your dad had a
pretty good life like he's a good guy
like a super stand-up dude Church leader
everything we're like yeah at least at
least he uh never did anything wrong and
my friend's like yeah at least he didn't
molest anyone at least I think
oh my
cause you can't
you can't baby that's just something at
least I think he didn't yeah yeah I love
the moment with Anthony when he's like
yeah well at least you know your dad
clicked the bell and he's he's a
subscriber and I'm like my dad's dead
I remember
bringing up more to Anthony every time
for a second I wasn't sure you were
talking about but then I realized you're
talking about regular Anthony
not cool Anthony he went over I would
never do that yeah cool nothing would
never even say is that your name Anthony
so we call him yeah he's the Charles
Anthony here
[Music]
foreign